check this out
this pizza is totally legal
totally healthy and i'm going to show
you how to make it
this is a great recipe the key is the
crust
this the crust is made with cauliflower
and mozzarella cheese there is no bread
there is no bad things there's no sugar
none of that in there no msg
and this isn't a cruciferous
pizza you can have it as much as you
want
and it's actually very very healthy for
you so
let me show you exactly how to make this
and just so you know you can have this
as much as you
want it will not cause weight gain so
let's show you how to make it
okay so now the secret to making this
pizza is in the crust
and i've made this 12 different times
and i've made every mistake in the book
i'm going to show you how to do it
correctly now the crust is very very
simple
two cups of cauliflower which by the way
is a cruciferous vegetable
because we can't use kale it's going to
be too green but cauliflower is a very
healthy
anti-aging has a lot of phytonutrients
and then we're going to use
mozzarella cheese okay so i'm going to
do organic
you don't have to do organic i just
recommend if you can find organic that
would be better
and two eggs whole eggs organic eggs or
free range eggs
so two cups of cauliflower two cups of
mozzarella cheese
shaved and two eggs and we're going to
mix it together
it's not going to seem like it's going
to make a crust but just watch and see
so simply we're going to make take the
cauliflower
and a grater you don't need a food
processor
and we're going to grade this
cauliflower down
very very simple
okay so now i would take out the big
chunks that didn't really
scrape in there we're just going to take
two cups
of this cauliflower two cups in a bowl
that's it obviously i made too much here
okay two cups unless you want two pizzas
okay
then we're going to just take this
organic
shredded mozzarella cheese you can get
fresh mozzarella
you could even use mozzarella goat
cheese if you want
but it just so happens that i already
know that this makes two cups
but i'll just show you right here so we
got one cup right here
okay and then two cups
see that all right
then we just simply take two eggs really
simple
yeah that's gonna work isn't it okay
there we go
all right you can tell that i'm not a
cook all right
but it seems to work now look at this
i have two eggs two cups of mozzarella
cheese and two cups of
cauliflower and we're just gonna mix
this around it's kind of weird because
it just doesn't seem to look like it's
going to make a crust
but it's going to you'll see
now don't put salt in it because the
mozzarella cheese is already
salty enough and i do see some bigger
little chunks here i'll take this out
because i don't want that chunk in there
all right we're just gonna mix it up
like that
that's what it looks like now check this
out i'm gonna just show you something
this is what the crust looks like
when we cook it look at this
it's crispy it's somewhat hard
that's what it's going to turn into so
it melts and it browns
and you're going to cook it for 15
minutes so the hardest part about this
whole
thing is making it on the parchment
paper
okay so let's talk about how we're going
to put this in here
get these little cheap little pizza pins
right here
and then we're going to take parchment
paper if you don't use parchment paper
it's going to be a little hard to get it
off there unless you put a lot of
olive oil underneath it so the hardest
part
is cutting the parchment paper to
this pan here so i'm going to just
attempt to do it right here
kind of work with it a little bit
i'm sure there's a technique to it i
don't know
so it didn't quite fit here
so i have to trim it up
now because this pizza has mozzarella
cheese it's somewhat
oily so you don't have to put any oil on
this pan so i'm going to show you right
here
i'm going to take this thing right here
and we are going to put it right in the
center
now just so you know i did wash my hands
so don't worry about that does dr berg
wash his hands
yes he does okay so now i'm going to
just take this thing right here
and i'm going to kind of even it up here
all right then i'm going to use my
washed hands
and start to press and flatten so
the secret number one is to
have the parchment paper secret number
two is to make it really thin
okay now there there are some
things i've tried like
taking some of the moisture out because
it's a little moist
in a microwave or even in the oven
it's not necessary it's really not so
i'm just
you can see that i have some more space
in here so i'm going to just start from
the center
and just kind of slowly kind of push it
towards the edge here
and flatten this thing right here okay
now i already pre heated the oven to 450
degrees so that's
all ready for us so
okay now
this is what it looks like very simple
we stick in the oven
40 for 15 minutes
okay and then it's going to come out
like
this right here so let's go ahead and
stick in the oven and
i'll show you the next step okay so we
got the crust
cooked at 15 minutes at 450 degrees now
we're going to put the sauce on it now
take a look you can use actual pizza
sauce or you can use
pasta sauce spaghetti sauce
so you just want to make sure that
it doesn't have that sugar or high
fructose corn syrup
this one's really really good this has
no sugars
it's a bit expensive but this would be
fine too this has no added sugars as
well
so it's not too bad it's trying to find
someone something with very low sugar
and we're just going to take this and
we're going to put a little tomato sauce
right
on the center there i did make the
mistake of putting
too much sauce so it really depends on
your taste so start off
putting just a little bit of sauce on it
and then see if it works
so i'm going to probably put a little
bit more sauce right here
in here
roughly a quarter cup so we're just
going to put the soft smeared around
now we're going to put some more
mozzarella cheese on it on the top so
i'm just going to take some cheese
sprinkle it
not too much just enough
okay so we got the cheese on there now
uh we're gonna put
some mushrooms
all right i love mushrooms i'm just
gonna cut these little
bad boys right here
put some mushrooms on it
okay then we're going to put a tomato
now this is a
real tomato you notice it's not perfect
it has a bunch of little holes in it
this is the good stuff this is what it
tastes it actually tastes really good
okay so we're just put some chunks on
there
now we're going to use some basil
all right so i've been growing some
basil out here for the pizza
so i'm going to just chop some of this
off right here
okay so with basil i'm just going to put
the whole leaf on it
i'm not going to cut it
but it adds a lot of flavor now we got
the basil on there
now i'm just you don't have to do this
i'm
using some pepperoni
because my kids like pepperoni and then
we're just going to put this
on there there we go
okay so i'm going to put a little
a little pepperoni on there
good so let's go ahead and stick in the
oven and let's see what happens
you